right good afternoon staff councillors
uh welcome along to this extraordinary
meeting of uh performance policy and
partnerships committee
uh those counsellors who are joining on
zuma if you can make sure that your
cameras are turned on to be uh
considered present please
mr morris you can leave yours off until
you're needed
we'll just let marcus get a selfie and
then we'll carry on
um we've got
no apologies
just councillors cricket coot clark
sober and abbott on
zoom uh first item on the agenda is the
youth council's report and really it's
just a matter of receiving this
councillor craic were you at that
meeting
i'll be your pardon sorry we've got a
major late item item seven um
which is a verbal report coming from mr
giblin
about uh the uh
education outside of the classroom
discussion that we had on last week
just an update on the position around
that so i'll move that it's received
there's a magella item seconded
councillor lewis put that all in favor
against carried
have we got a minor one
i'm sorry the major i've got it the
wrong way around the major
was the minutes
because they weren't really the minor is
the um
verbal update
so i'll
with councillor lewis's absolutely sent
amend the motion to receiving the major
and minor later items
put that all in favor
against carried
third time lacking
the youth council report sorry
councillor craic were you at that
meeting
no i was in isolation at the time
you want a move that it's received
absolutely
i'll second it
any questions or comments
their first meeting of the year
um
generally i don't think they've gotten
around to electing their heads yet
but they'll start to appear after their
next meeting
put the motion all in favor hi
carried
so we've got the
minutes of the committee meeting uh on
february 8th
somebody wants to move those sorry who
was that
counselor evanson and seconded
councillor bottinger
any matters arising
if not i'll put that motion all in favor
against
carrie
minutes of the extraordinary meeting on
february 17th
for a mover
a scout council a partner
any matters
and if not i'll put that motion all in
favor
against
carried
the minutes from uh february 22nd
council of scouts moved councillor lewis
any comments
i'll put that motion all in favor
against carrie
uh application for grant funding for the
2022 ilt learn to swim
steve really oh sorry mr cocker i didn't
see you lurking there welcome
um this is
a similar procedure to what we went
through last year and just we need a
formal resolution to apply for the
funding yep that's correct
relatively straightforward any questions
for
stephen while he's here
it's two resolutions simply prepared oh
sorry are you moving
yep
look it's just regarding uh has there
been any indication from the ilt
if there's a potential drop from this is
obviously from the foundation
and the funding is that right
rlt foundation
through youtube this is through the
trust and the foundation the trust and
the foundation
so some from the trading arm some from
the foundation that is correct okay yeah
i was just wondering how the foundation
went through the years you know through
the covert
exactly
there's been no indication that any
issues in this stage
cool
we'll see how it goes at the application
stage
so looking for a mover for the two
recommendations
i'll move
councillor abbott sector reverend cook
are you voting or have you got a
question counselor arnold
got one thank you
i'll put the motion then all in favor
against
carried
thanks stephen
grant
big red chair
uh
here we get to the district plan the
effectiveness and monitoring report
do you
want to introduce the
paper for us
yeah sure thing i'll just give a brief
summary of the report and um
what we're talking about today
so the structure of the full report
attached is summarized in the four
bullet points of the start of the
covering committee report
one thing to note is that report the
report's not seeking a decision per se
instead really it's asking
the committee to endorse our recommended
directions on where to next for the
district plan
overall these are
one producing an invercargill
city-centric detailed housing capacity
report
two improving our understanding of
natural hazards that impact on our city
and its resilience and development
capacity
three continue our ongoing monitoring of
the provisions within the district plan
highlights of which include
comparative volumes of the number of
building consents versus resource
consents
and this will assist in determining a
sense of conversion rate from where
development goes from just needing a
building consent to needing a resource
consent
improving our complaints monitoring and
recording including volumes types and
locations of complaints
work on housing density and urban design
requirements including things like
minimum site size and yard size and
location requirements
ensuring an integrated approach to
infrastructure and equip in order to
make sure our transport and three waters
networks
are well designed and resilient and just
on that i think there's a good example
of where perhaps this hasn't occurred um
and that's up later in on in your agenda
for the naming of a new road off gimlet
street
um
and i think with that one if you have a
look at the area you'll note this lack
of full connectivity through gimlet
street so it's just highlighting that as
um
is a potential issue in the future
and looking at business and mixed use
signs to ensure our existing commercial
areas are vibrant and attractive to
businesses and there's some further
discussion
in my report and the full report around
that
um but overall um you know from here i'm
in the committee's hands and happy to
answer any questions you may have in
terms of the report i appreciate there's
quite a bit of detail in it so
um yeah anticipation there might be some
queries thanks grant so essentially
we're setting a tone for how we go about
a review essentially yeah
counselor partner um look i've got two
things one is is a
basically
following up on vogel street and
obviously there's a development in
behind there uh northwood estate
and and just wondering what the current
impact is
on traffic going down vogel street
obviously it gets bigger and bigger and
bigger it seems to behind there and just
wondering
is that an instance of
something that's got too big or is it
still under control
but traffic entering because that's the
only access to it yeah look um
i haven't had any sort of i can answer
that detail yes sure thank you thank you
um so around that the
uh
amount of subdivision cannot increase
until there's another traffic increase
progressed okay so is it it's
what has been consented and there are
still some unfilled properties yeah um
is as far as it can go until there's
another way out right okay
uh the second question was regarding
about um the productive capability of
land now talked about you know turning
good land and you know wasting it on
urban you know you saw
but unfortunately around the country um
people are turning really good farmland
planting trees on it
to claim carbon credits
and not using the land at all
no thought of cutting down the trees now
it seems to be the government is
allowing that to happen in fact i think
they're encouraging it
yet we
i see you're doing the right thing by
making sure that productive good soils
are still being used for you know for
agriculture yeah i think you might have
seen in the report perhaps as well
that the minimum lot size in the rural
zone for invicargo city is actually
quite small as well like two hectares
and um
there's some spatial plans shown in the
report which show
where subdivision has has occurred down
to the minimum two hectare lot size and
really is that conducive for sustained
agricultural use
because
you know can you run a viable
farm or agricultural operation or you
know food source um at two hectares
so yeah it sort of amazes me that almost
some people like
that lifestyle of having land but
sometimes they end up with too much
yeah it's actually a bit of a curse you
know they've got to either bail it or
do something with it yeah sure yeah oh
yeah well certainly there is a bit of
tension around the
existing provisions in our district plan
for what you can do as a right in the
rural zone
okay thanks
thank you
any other questions
your worship are we going to be taking
action on that this year
i've been lobbied on that by
uh the rural sector and
there's a high level of concern about
pioneers radiator in particular you've
got to
realize that there's different
sort of horses for courses when it comes
to planting trees
are we following up on this report from
memory your worship i'm not sure that
our district plan
provides any prescription around the
types of trees that people are able to
grow on on their properties
but
and i know that there are some controls
that are covered off regionally but
that would be something that could
potentially be
considered through this this process
thank you councillor amundsen
thanks um two questions one is what do
you think the time frame might be on the
housing capacity assessment
um because housing is a huge need so it
would be good to have that as soon as
possible my other question is around
is it going to focus solely on
things that the council can do or look
at
with the district plan or is it able to
be a little bit more broadly focused
because there's other things that i
think the council can affect potentially
that might help enable more housing
so i'll answer your second question
first i think it'll be more of a broad
assessment
but also delve into uh some of the
actual provisions in our plan as well
you know perhaps some provisions which
might be disenabling
market investment for example in the
residential 1a zone which is our medium
density residential zone that's one of
the ones that i've kind of looked into
the most
in terms of time frame i mean i would
like to um
we've already been um sort of chipping
away at some of the background data um
[Music]
over the last
six months i suppose
it's likely that we'll need to engage
some expert
input into that from the economic side
of things
so
without holding anything to anything i'd
like to say within the sort of next six
to twelve months
thank you reverend cook
as a follow-up to what council anderson
asked i see that you've identified a
medium density zone but you haven't
identified any high density zones for
housing
and given that some of the requirements
for housing are for people who don't
want large houses they just want
somewhere to live um so one to two
bedrooms small sized lots have we got
any policy have you identified any areas
has been any work done
thinking about those sorts of
questions so i think that question would
um
be asked and addressed in the housing
capacity assessment
um
really that's around the
the type
in particular and location of housing
um and i expect that the question of
high density housing will be
raised in that report as well and
addressed through that
but certainly we only have medium
density residential provisions in our
current district plan
so just speaking to that i think that's
that's one of those areas where there's
been quite a bit of movement
um we've seen
the desire for the traditional quarter
acre section uh reducing more people
looking for
low maintenance smaller properties
the higher density does create other
issues for us that we've got to work
around drainage for example but
given the pressure on housing and if we
can encourage urban infill
it's one of those things that we'd
certainly want to review and i think
there's been movement from when the
district plan was last done
to to this point
sorry did i miss another hand
you comfortable with that
thank you
okay um
there are two recommendations that the
reports received and we endorsed the
recommendations as outlined in part four
councillor anderson's moving i'll second
it
counselor super do you have a question
no counselor parting sorry there was one
more question i didn't
forget to
ask and it's quite
relevant and
and
i guess today this climate we're facing
with with drought and
the report states that we are looking
for more droughts that are coming um
is there any thought of
provisions in the plan for
people retaining water on site a certain
amount of water
for housing
i mean it's been talked about loosely in
the past but
if if this drought
thing is serious
you know
uh there's no recommendations on the
report of course
i wonder if that's something that would
be addressed through the building
consent process um but it is something
that obviously we can look at through
the um any
amendment to provisions within the
district plan itself as well so i mean
that this
recommendations in here aren't uh the
bill and end all of everything we're
looking at obviously this is just the
high level stuff and and probably uh the
most pressing matters for our city um
but certainly it wouldn't prevent us
having a look at
you know impacts on the city and in
terms of climate change et cetera
i think in areas where
there's no high-pressure main system
it's obviously encouraged for
firefighting purposes but there's no
reason that a review can't endorse or
encourage people to gather roof water or
groundwater for
reuse
thanks
so i think from memory it's done quite
extensively in australia as well
in
urban situations
any other questions or comments
if not it's been moved and seconded i'll
put that all in favor okay
against
carried thank you thank
the
you
well-being fund
um
two recommendations in there
michael welcome
good afternoon
um
good afternoon everybody very simple uh
report
with councillor cracker deciding to step
back from this fund
um
we need to i mean the governance
statement was a replacement councillor
sopa has indicated she is willing to
step in
but this of course is the decision for
council
to make so while council sopa has
indicated she's willing to step in this
is a decision for the committee to
recommend on to council
um
happy to answer any questions but it
should be a relatively straightforward
procedural report
i'll move the appointment of counsellors
thank you council rabbit and secondary
council second but also i'd like to make
a comment if i may chair that i really
appreciate the input that council
cracker has made over the years that
i've been associated with the community
wellbeing fund and thank councillor
safer for stepping up to the plate
and thank you very much both of you
thanks for those comments it's been
moved and seconded to council as i put
the motion all in favor
against
carried
while you're there michael are you
dealing with this next issue as well
the name change
that is missed today
ah pretty bad sorry michael
looking at the wrong michael
you can never have too many michaels
thank you through yourself chair this is
um a proposed name
as you heard through the district plan
there may be concerns around the
subdivision are the
industrial area itself but the
subdivision is an approved subdivision
this is the naming within the
subdivision in relation to the road so
it's been through
uh man of manifenua representation uh
review and through the roonaka so
um
if there's i'll leave it open to any
questions
thank you are there any
somebody like to move the
recommendations reverend cook second act
counselor kit
any further comments
if not it's been moved and seconded i'll
put the motion all in favor
which brings us to the activities report
uh mr chair just before we start that
report i will have to apologize for
departing at this stage my flight is
just being called
no problem counsellor and i'll signal
that in the next item uh we'll be
placing that correction that you've
pointed out to the minutes
thank you very much thank you bye
everyone see you tomorrow
right trudy yara koto councillors your
worship uh i'd just like to draw
attention to the improved performance
for our non-notified
resource consent and the team continue
to remain highly focused
on meeting our required time frames
we continue to
in terms of our building consents we're
still delivering a great experience in
that space
in terms of the turnaround time
and while we have seen the number of
customers drop back there's still
at our rates time we see a peak come in
to pay over the counter
and i'll pass on to mr gibbling to
highlight any
pieces of his world just before you do
that um recognize a quick turnaround in
that uh changing reporting as well with
the
dishes that we reported on at the last
meeting so thank you for that steve
thank you mr chair councillors your
worship
just one point tonight in the report
and it's part of our ongoing approach to
improving our reporting around the
collections at
south museum and art gallery the team up
to the end of january have
packed and be ready for relocation about
76
of
the items within our collection and
i know that they've made further
progress over the last month and we'll
be bringing more detailed reporting on
that but happy to take any questions
before i pass to mr day
no questions for steve
michael d
thank you
yourself the chair um i'm going to take
my sections as being read it's
merely indicating to the councillors
around these bylaws that are coming up
for consultation
fairly soon
hearing sit down for that
this month
yes there is council
thank you any questions from us today
councillor
clarke yeah probably probably more for
steve um just wondering what the
progress was on anderson
thank you councillor
um look in terms of the construction
program i think it's noted the
construction program is to time
um
uh venues and events manager richard
mccoy is working with the anderson house
trust at the moment around the proposal
for the future operation
and that will be coming back to or
through richard at this stage
within the next month
about what that future service looks
like
what
just on that when does that come back to
to council for consideration
uh i need to confirm the time frame so
it should be within the next two months
okay thanks just looking for something
indicative
you're comfortable with that counselor
clark
yeah yeah thank you thanks
there are other questions move that the
activities report is received
zero second councillor scout thank you
put that all in favor
okay
against
carried
and the minutes of the extraordinary
meeting uh from march 1st there's one
amendment that needs to be made and that
is that we need to include councillor
sopa as being present particularly since
i think she is the mover of a couple of
motions in there
so with that amendment councilor lewis
will move seconded by councillor skill
any comments
if not i put the motion all in favor
against
carried
there are no further items
that i've got in open so i'll move that
we go into public excluded for the
reasons that's laid out in the minutes
uh the exception to be
obviously the attention oh i beg your
pardon sorry thank you steve for waving
that paper furiously at me
we do have the
minor light item
uh thank you chair um
[Music]
last tuesday i briefed the committee on
the potential changes that were related
to the education outside the classroom
and noted some of the issues at that
time would make it impossible for
council to accommodate those programs
within our facilities
we also heard from andrew cameron that
the use of the mandatory vaccine passes
was a decision of council
and that council could remove that
requirement
so we we didn't progress any further
from that point aside from saying that
we will bring back a report in april
around the future
use of the mandatory vaccine pass
however the following day on wednesday i
received an email from sport new zealand
and claire also received an email
through the chief executives network
from the department of internal affairs
indicating that the minister of
education has signaled further changes
to the covert 19 protection framework
for curricular and extracurricular
school activities including the
education outside the classroom program
indicated that this change will take
place no later than the 15th of march
and it will be legislated
these changes specifically will apply to
council venues that are used for these
activities
and require a vaccine pass so this these
new changes mean that for these venues
the vaccine past requirements will be
illegal for those participating in
school-related activities curricular or
extracurricular
the skilled children will in practice be
exempt from any vaccine past
requirements imposed by council
further consistent with the original
exemption for these venues from
mandatory vaccine passes there will be
no requirement for facilities partition
of space for these groups
in order to require
to comply sorry for the eotc
requirements this means essentially that
children and young people are in school
organized team group or individual
activity cannot be asked for a vaccine
pass and must be treated by the activity
organizer or venue operator as if they
were vaccinated
so we understand that public health is
supportive of removing the requirements
for the mvps for school sport noting the
high levels of vaccination coverage in
the 12 to 17 year old age group
new zealand's changing strategic
approach to omicron outbreak and the
importance of school sport on student
wellbeing consistency with activities
allowed during school time
and the lower transmission risks in this
setting compared to other settings
so we advised the committee last week
the central government had indicated
that did not intend for vaccine mandates
to be applied to school activities as
we're looking into eitc and mvp
relationships
council was asked whether it wished to
review the current mandate policy in
light of those statements and we
determined again that we'll bring that
paper back in april
so essentially once the legislation is
passed
council will not be able to apply its
vaccine mandate policy to these children
and that is likely to occur on or around
the 15th of march
so just clarifying that will happen
as a matter of legislation and is
outside of council's policy
and i guess
the timeliness of the full review that
we were looking at in mid late april
doesn't really shift but that's up to
council council can review its policy
at any stage
councillor amundsen just a question
clarification
so this only applies to school related
activities not club activities or if
somebody just wanted to go to the
swimming pool on the weekend and we're
unvaccinated they couldn't do that it's
only if they're going with school or
because of school
that they have that exemption yes
council that is correct and it is
they have to be associated with the
school activity
so they could attend say for example
splash palace on a friday evening to
play water polo and the vaccination
exemption would apply
whereas on saturday morning going for a
slide on the hydro slide they would need
to have the vaccine pass at this point
another question of clarification before
i come to councillor pottinger
um and michael
mr morris you might like to have your
ear on this one too
what about parents who are accompanying
those children on those school trips
they would not be exempt
uh that would be a matter for the
education outside the classroom criteria
to me but i understand that is the case
okay
counselor partner i think
i guess i guess i'm beating nigel to the
gun here
is
um
sports activities at the stadium that
that's a massive venue that you could
have a
potentially a school sport tournament
which is
class the same i take it
and so and and say you got the big
community courts there 5 000 square
metres
um you could
fit in heaps of people playing netball
volleyball whatever i mean at the moment
it's heavily restricted to a hundred
people for five thousand square meters
so that's all out the door come the 15th
no
that's not my understanding no that's
isn't that extra sport curricula the the
requirement for a vaccination
mandate passport
um or the mandatory vaccination passport
that's the thing that changes for this
that's what i mean um but all of the
other criteria under the red phase and
phase three they all still apply for
those
large scale gatherings and events
but it'd be fair to say until we
actually see the content of the
legislation
we're just providing you an update on
the direction of travel that the central
government agencies have sent us
the legislation hasn't been drafted and
we haven't received any further detail
about
any other changes we just understand
it's related to education outside the
classroom and the mandatory vaccination
passport requirement for public
facilities
right so the stadium is a public
facility if you have a sports day and it
doesn't have to be an outdoor sports day
as far as athletics go it could be an
indoor sports day so that still is
determined by
the hundred people type thing correct
yeah that's about mis miscued isn't it
because they're still working through
that yes
so yeah that is correct and that's we
can't really probably comment no no
that's not us effective details of the
facilities but we do also want to signal
that this is this will apply to
hawakituya and will also apply to the
library
we've got advice through sport new
zealand about splash palace
but it's the program that can run in all
three of those facilities so it will be
something that we'll need to look at for
all three facilities
that their council own and operate
councillor lush
sorry just to clarify that
the polls would if we allowed people to
run vaccinated would that reduce the
capacity from 100 to 25
because of the pull and the way we have
set up the capacities we
we do
have unique operating circumstances in
there we can put more than 100 people in
those facilities
each facility is unique and so we've got
a capacity on there
um
the top of my heat i can't recall but
it's well over 100 in this phase of
operation
um
that's part of the advice we're bringing
back as to what are these changes mean
for our operations and so i can't really
give you that concrete advice right now
but that will be following coming back
in april thanks
any other questions counselors counselor
scalp thank you through youtube i think
the key to the matter is that again
the message that's been given um if we
are we if we as venue operators and
managers and
as a council team are having difficulty
understanding the latest edict that's
come now
the issue we have already from parents
is the
very clear
confusion they have
around their child going to the pool on
fridays and within a school group then
whipping down there on saturday all the
same for a sports team coming into the
venue
and what you started himself an example
with the team on during the week
and then playing the team on saturday
netball girls high play girls high
players girls high
where does that leave us in that
situation then we have the designated
hundreds still for the venue
so all i'm saying is again we have a
lack of clarification
right throughout the country within
venues around this piece and i
understand it's new there's a update
last night steve will be aware but it's
still at the moment extremely confusing
my major concern is for the venue
managers dealing with the
mums and the dads and the caregivers
we've got a massive anonymity on the
current policy as it sits on the current
policy i no doubt stephen will get some
more information next but it's at the
moment it's exceptionally confusing
we're getting massive feedback from
parents
no ted
councillors uh councillor clark sorry
thank you chair just a couple of issues
i wanted to clarify with steve because
at one stage he said there would be
implications for council
but then he made the reference to public
facilities and they're two different
things of course
because we don't own every public
facility and a good example is stadium
south and we don't own
that as a public facility it's owned by
trust
um so they might they're saying that the
current feedback you're getting on the
education outside classroom
is
has an impact for council
council facilities at it
and that it allows
access at times that they would normally
be in the classroom but they elect to go
to swimming or whatever
but it also allows for sports teams that
might be recognized under a particular
school is that what i'm here i can see
you're nodding yes that's correct
counselor
thank you
all right councillors it's it's really
informative um at this stage you have
already resolved to review in mid-april
so
i'll move that mr goblin's verbal report
is received
seconded by councillor amundsen
further comments or questions
sorry through youtube i just wondered
through steve
should the legislation change
dramatically steve
going forward within the next 10 days do
you envisage that we may have to make a
a pretty abrupt change
three mr g look if if the law changes uh
we will have to follow the law yeah and
um if that changes significantly beyond
what we've advised here i think we will
be bringing back some more information
to this
council very quickly just so that you
understand the changes that we now have
to follow
thank you
councillor clark
just as a follow-up chair to uh
councillor scott's uh feedback um i'm
i'm not sure it's wise for us to leave
that that next consideration to the 12th
of april
i think even if we don't make any
decisions earlier that we should still
um come together somewhere along the
line as soon as we know what the
legislation is doing because there is
going to be a mass amount of
inconsistency around things like you can
come for water poll on a friday night
because there's a combination coming on
but
whether you deal with boys high versus
boys high on a saturday they might be
wanting to practice their water pollen i
mean
we shouldn't leave it another four
months after the legislation kicked in
we've got enough
criticism already from small sector of
the public about the uh
about the applications or the passports
in our facilities and we should look at
uh certainly if he walketh in the
library and
um swimming pool uh sooner than later on
that so i so if there's something clear
and concrete that comes through that is
dramatically different we have an
opportunity to call an extraordinary pvp
on either the 15th or the 22nd
or the 29th and and deal with them as as
exponentially as we can
thank you thanks
so much that the report is received
counselor sorry miss reverend cook
just to comment um for clarification
do we not have a quite low loading for
hiwaka toyo already
so
the implications
for that in terms of
education outside of the classroom would
be a classroom sized group going in
because that would be the capacity
so the
changes required there
might be minimal except that other
public can go in there as well so you've
got a mixed message you've got people
who are attending because they want to
um having to be vast past
and a school group going in there who
are not
and that's the issue of equity that
council will have to deal with it isn't
it
and yeah if i can answer that question
because it is
it is quite relevant to this topic the
defined airspace was one of the changes
that have been signaled to change
and that defined airspace was enabling
uh separate groups to partake in an
activity without
um crossing over in a way the the air
bubbles within a facility that
requirement by the sounds of it will be
removed from this legislation and that
means that you can have public and
school children interacting within the
same year environment
and again that's why we've got to wait
for the legislation to confirm the exact
details on how we then implement this in
our three facilities
so through you mr chair that's what i
wish to comment on is that would be
premature of us to presume that in this
very rapidly changing environment what
has been signaled to us will be what we
receive on the 15th
because with
the number of cases that are
exponentially exploding around the place
that may be a rethink about this we
shouldn't actually make a decision today
presuming what it might be next week
i don't think we have enough information
to make a new decision at this point
anyway
councillor pardon you um yeah just
clarity on that we we actually don't
make the decision it's legislation as
steve said we do what we're told if the
government decided
sorry the decision was around council
policy ah yeah well that's that's that's
never going to change is it
well we've agreed to review it
okay anything else
if not it's been moved and seconded i'll
put the motion all in paper all right
against
carried
this
time i'll move that we go into public
excluded to confirm the minutes of ppppx
from february 8th and february 22nd
and to receive the property investments
update report
excluding obviously mr grant and for the
reasons as laid out in their gender
second for that councilor lewis i'll put
it all in favor
against carried for those who've joined
us on the live stream thank you enjoy
the rest of your afternoon
you